[Music]
in parental neglect news submitted by
Apple greater than Android yeah ah yeah
right yeah but I don't even like it oh I
like I like Android better but it
appeared pressured you're weak
well like androids and you get peer
pressure no you know what it is it's
Apple's close that system [ __ ] like the
idea of getting a new phone because I
want an Android but having to import all
my photos and [ __ ] is just a nightmare
it is you don't have a cloud or anything
like that I don't know how to I don't
know they're not even that advanced have
a cloud Wow think about the Android then
yeah you do more [ __ ] what [ __ ] are you
gonna do all kind of cool [ __ ] Bart I
can run this [ __ ] server from my
phone like that can power internet and
[ __ ] holes the sound real good yeah do
that too if you want
Google I might yeah all right I was
looking at the galaxy
I'm never gonna text you and I'm only
gonna block your number I don't want
that waiting until I have until I
actually make the change I don't want a
green bubble hey tell you to wait please
wait unlimited storage because it cooks
it hooks up to your Google Drive and
then you get unlimited google drive
space
like many Apple we gotta buy that [ __ ] I
just had to pay for more storage so I
could take more pictures because if you
delete any pictures on an Apple phone it
deletes it on the cloud so I'm like [ __ ]
you guys oh yeah so you can't just have
your phone clear of all pictures yeah I
hate the cloud I hate that one he
deleted all the [ __ ] off his desktop
just to like clean it up and then it
ended up deleting from the cloud forever
you've lost so many document yes you
can't restore it somehow we can't figure
out I don't use cloud ever apples is a
[ __ ] joke dude I hate those guys even
though I was named never Steve Jobs so
it totally sucks yeah we're talking
about him
CEO yeah Steve Jobs his daughter wrote a
heartbreaking memoir about their brutal
relationships
oh you use a beater no oh why when I
think boot I think I thought he hit her
hands that's sad
no but that's what the definition of
brew is isn't it
yeah mortality yeah of it yeah that's a
misuse of it that okay you guys are
correct we don't know anything no I'm
just in terms of like English right yeah
I don't know like sexual abuse is like
like is that like yeah it's the literal
translation for brutality it's brutal
right that's just what I thought I don't
know I thought you Steve does like yeah
I thought he was being a violent person
I don't know okay the violence doesn't
exist in your world but it doesn't
matter that's always think they view as
hugs
yeah you're we do need hugs ah we do we
do you know hey hey hey no one could you
know hugs hugs is something that
everyone needs all the time just like in
our movie we try to solve crime with hug
the more you talk the more you sound
like a boxer that's like at the end of
their career yeah we took a lot of hits
man was this Trina's like you're not
doing one more fight not one more but I
got it I got it
yeah but the big buddy first families
already got enough blow out of your
blood on my hand
his record skips a lot I just [ __ ]
had a sentence like that a sentence of
Google Drive it yeah right so Lisa she
Lisa is - birthday happy birthday Lisa
oh yeah Michael Jackson was good
remember when he was fat he's that
Michael Jackson was super fat in the
Simpsons yeah the characters ever it was
all right so this why was he fat he was
in a psychiatric ward and he thought
that he was Michael Jackson but he
wasn't yeah but then it was actual
Michael Jackson doing the voice yes
thank God we figured that out
it was so pressing on his mind no cuz I
thought it was actual Michael Jackson
that let himself go got it good to know
good to know that's what we thought
that's what we thought you meant after
all right so this is Lisa Lisa jobs
Brendon job oh yeah so she seems happy
yeah she when she was born both of her
parents were 23 years old and would deny
her as his daughter because was their
mama ho was Shady
according to the according to the movie
yeah what like she was a [ __ ] like she
watched the movie Steve Jobs was an
[ __ ]
what you wouldn't even think that in
that movie because it was told through
friends I read the book by Walter
Isaacson that the movies based on dog oh
you're that person the book was way
better no the movies always better
because it like hate did I actually
don't right now okay she doesn't like to
read no I usually agree with people like
[ __ ] you I hate those people but I'm
that guy right now it's all good cuz the
movie was like all in one hour for him
and [ __ ] I don't know is this the Ashton
Kutcher's no no no but that one was
funny no one was good I liked that one
the Fassbender one which one came first
it doesn't matter I need to know them is
my garbage tier and the other one is
like a good a good issue V but the
Fassbender was the garbage one right
yeah yeah totally actually good sure
nailed the walk though mm-hmm to see him
walk into that [ __ ] moment Whitney
when I saw the trailer to that I was
like I'm not watching this look the only
time he's acting in the whole [ __ ]
movie is when he's walking he's like I
really got the wall still Celso I did it
yeah he was just talking on you Ashton
Kutcher the whole time
alright so Lisa wrote a memoir
it's called small fry and it has details
about her difficult relationship with
her father so like I said in the
beginning of her life he would refuse
her as his daughter but they look
exactly alike
I met her a couple days after she was
born she wasn't even there when she was
born they had to go to court and a judge
had to order a paternity test for him to
finally acknowledge her as his daughter
and so he finally did so they wouldn't
have like weekend meetups and stuff they
would she would come go over to his
house and if you recognize during you
when I named her I baby baby well he
named a computer out of direction in the
Lisa computer can somebody catch me up
to this [ __ ] love triangle I don't
know like were they married or like what
okay there were just [ __ ] buddies yeah
oh we're dated they dated and then they
had the baby so he [ __ ] busted nuts
all in her yeah she didn't believe in AI
condoms
no okay then he blew and then he was
like doing Apple it's like that ain't my
kid
I got Apple to deal with yeah yeah
pretty much he would even give her money
yeah this man to force a paternity test
to get money to get you worse than an
athlete dude at least athletes pay yeah
right after they force a paternity test
almost every time damn that's why
athletes are better nerds that's true
nerves don't pay so yes he did
but now he loves her no he loves her now
yeah yeah but he was there for ten
minutes he met her a few days after she
was born this is her with your mom and
so she's just this little excerpt from
her memoir she's detailing how when she
was growing up that she always saw him
as like a hero and I always looked up to
him and stuff but every time he was
around her she would always be really
cold with her and there was at one point
where she overheard her mom and the
boyfriend talking about how they think
that they switch out that they think
that he switches out his Porsches every
time he gets a scratch because it's too
expensive to paint or whatever and so
that's when Lisa had in her child's mind
that like oh you know that's so cool
like maybe one day he could give me one
so then when she was older she asked him
so entitled is this book old I never got
a poor yeah well he ended up responding
Oh cuz she asked
and then he ended up responding you're
not getting anything you understand
nothing you're getting nothing and then
later on - she also asked if he he named
the Apple Lisa after her and then he
immediately just responded no and like
just really I named it after the
Simpsons but then later on like few
years later they she accompanied them to
a trip in Italy I believed and that's
when they went to Bono's house and then
at Bono's house Bono asked him did you
name the computer after your daughter
and that's when he said yup but he like
hesitated so it's just like little
details like that of like how her
relationship was with her father and
it's kind of sad wondered the backstory
though like how did it get there and why
does he feel that way he was weird man
he wouldn't he [ __ ] over his closest
friend is this you know a sociopath
probably is a genius yeah like people
who worked in Apple Computer and they
didn't get shares like they would come
into his office and ask and he'd say you
get nothing and like [ __ ] off basically
like it was like that yeah was it
Wozniak Steve Wozniak yeah Wozniak
basically built the [ __ ] with them but
he doesn't have jack dude no no he does
Wozniak civilian really oh yeah okay
wasn't it did really well I thought they
had a fallen now it was a bunch of other
guys on the on the dev team or whatever
they had a turbulent relationship yeah
for sure yes he better but I would have
been mad for him but Steve Jobs I think
had severe attachment issues which is
what I identified with because I
definitely have that to where he like
when he when when he's walking through
the Apple building they had a bunch of
old Apple computers Allen display like
to remember like the Apple 2 and the
[ __ ] whole bunch of Dilys in Anza and
he asked that all of them be removed
from the campus and like gotten rid of
because he never wants to think about
the past he only wants to be looking
towards the future and I think that Lisa
for him was a mistake that he made and
so he constantly took it out on her like
she's like a relic of a him that he
hated
damn that sex yeah she is she was like a
steam that's why the movies better
effect record is what she said Wow
this guy's [ __ ] Harless yeah he's
pretty he's pretty merciless about that
[ __ ] crazy always named dr. Steve Jobs
if a girl came up to me right now and
she has a she has a kid and let's say
it's like it looks a hundred percent
black and [ __ ]
and they're like that's your baby I'll
be like oh my god really
I'll start feeding on McDonald's for no
reason [ __ ] and you'll take them in and
then let them live if you [ __ ] teach
him karate everything all that [ __ ] even
if I didn't [ __ ] that girl I'm like damn
I don't know how but I guess stork do is
Wonder silence why are you even
promoting that so many girls are gonna
so damning you right now yeah out of the
woodwork dude who they come yeah but you
know there's gonna be one lucky just
condition that kid is mine and she has
to leave the whole entire picture
that's my new mom Jessup cuz jess is
gonna be a better mother and they
probably don't want the kid that much if
they're gonna bring it to me yep and I'm
gonna build many soldiers many many cute
little so you must really not know their
child if they're bringing mm-hmm and
they're gonna be smart and they're gonna
be really funny and they're gonna be
really good at the arts of medieval
warfare with swords and you're just a
kid bragging a playground right now
that's what you are
[Music]